all right we're back with the incredible
my favorite alana glazer
well in honor of um your motherhood um
if it's okay um i'd love to do the final
five with you but we could make it mom
edition i love it all right
[Applause]
you're you're slaying drew you're
killing it okay i'm gonna ask you five
questions about being a mom and you need
to answer honestly okay babies have
distinct cries can you give us your best
hungry cry
for an infant
um
[Music]
it's like i guess i could cry like
but she's like
yeah there you go
it's high it's a thin tone
it was so great when the pediatrician
because i would call him all the time
like so hypochondriacal and he was like
you'll know the cry that makes you call
me for real i love it i was like ooh
okay thank you dr waldstein um did your
feet get bigger
no
all the weight and water and growth
happened in uh my chest area so
interesting i grew three shoe sizes
three three i went from a six to another
inverse wild and then my whole shoe
collection i donated damn i mean that's
an investment you know and that was
really bummed
i was trying to be carrie bradshaw and
yeah
damn more like dr scholes
okay what is one item from your baby
registry that you cannot live without
um
you know what uh an amazing stand-up
comedian yamaneika sounders new york
through and through got us this mobile
from nordstrom pink i really like didn't
want like it's just like nice to look at
and it was like a little forest of
rattles a mushroom rattle a little snail
rattle and it really um for six months
it was just so uh entertaining to my
baby a
mobile from
nordstrom
it sounds really happy i want one yeah
um if you have adult things laying
around what age do you think no we'll
just start hiding that
um
i guess so they're like right now i'm
thinking of the kitchen like these
things are on the counter
i would say at age
three
between two and three it's time to
get the like lock boxes i i'm so mad
because i have one for you and it's just
not here yet oh but i bought you a lock
box oh i can't believe you said it i'll
wait i'll wait and here's the best part
about this lock box it's a code so you
don't have to lose the key and do that i
love it love it what's your biggest mom
fail
you know what i have to stop doing is
i'm i'm q-tipping the boogers out of her
nose
and it's kind of compulsive and i just
need to stop and let them come out as
they come
have you ever had to do the nose frida i
i have it on hand yes
i don't know what was wrong with me i
was sucking my kids snot out like it was
i mean that's love yeah
if you don't know what this is it's
basically a booger straw yeah for you
and your baby and you yes
because sometimes like it sometimes it's
stuck and they can't breathe and when
they can't breathe they can't sleep so
believe me you start sucking that's
right
elonic laser i have waited for so long
to meet you to have this moment with you
my daughter and i are your biggest fans
you and abby we are always cheering you
on um both individually and together and
it is just such an honor to finally make
your acquaintance i'm honored i am
honored you are so generous to me
all right the new episodes of the after
party are available fridays on apple tv
plus and um
just
oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]